research shows there is still inequality
at home with women taking on most
household responsibilities one of the
new york times most shared articles this
week is called what good dads get away
with we like that title it impacts why
women still handle most of the childcare
and chores one study estimates it will
be listen to this another 75 years
before men do half the unpaid work at
home the article by clinical
psychologist Darcy Lachlan is based on a
new book it's called all the rage
mothers and fathers and the myth of
equal partnership dr. Lachman joins us
at the table to discuss now when we read
this a lot of men are shaking their
heads going no Darcy you're wrong but
you call the division of labor the most
I didn't say are they really because
aren't they saying iron we were busted
that's one way to look at it the
division of labor is the most important
equity issues of our time and you you
make the article very personal about
what was going on in your house you and
your husband were both working parents
of two daughters and he thought what and
you thought why there's so much work
involved when children come around yes
everyone's doing a ton more so it's hard
for fathers sometimes to see the
proportionality of it and because of our
assumptions about who the primary
parents should be it often just defaults
to the woman and what I found in my
research is women are really angry about
it yeah but you said that he thought he
was doing a good job then you were
nagging a lot and you thought I'm not
really nagging yeah yeah I hate the word
nagging but you weren't bringing it I
wasn't enough yes we had a very
different take on it and he's a great
dad it wasn't about the fathering it was
the co-parenting piece and this is where
I found a lot of women are really
frustrated and of course to the person
who's being told hey you need to step up
your game who already feels like they're
doing quite a lot it became it became a
point of contention as it often does
I interviewed about 50 women for the
book and I saw this a virus all around
me where Tommy well I found that this
predicament is so predictable and I
think what has happened is there's this
kind of idea of the modern involved
father who's way more involved than like
Don Draper right who's sort of like what
we all hold in our minds as the 50s dad
so there has been a lot of improvement
and how much
parenting work men do but actually the
percentage which the Bureau of Labor
Statistics consistently shows is about
35% of that's how much of the childcare
work fathers take on that's held study
for the last 20 years so the numbers
climb but they leveled off without ever
reaching parity and a lot of parents
today go into this expecting parity so
when it doesn't manifest there's a lot
of upset what about the happiness of
people who don't expect parity we have
them what would be called more
traditional yeah it is a good question
the thing that I found was that if
couples had outlined their expectations
it almost didn't matter how the work was
divided but most couples don't think to
do that you don't know all that goes
into raising a kid all the kind of
behind the scenes labor until you have
one and you encounter it so people don't
tend to get together and say how are we
gonna do this and it all kind of comes
on and then it often defaults to mother
so the default defaulting to the mother
is where there's a problem if people
have agreed to live traditionally that's
fine until Mother's do get frustrated
there's also nonverbal work which is to
say as Nancy Gibbs at time used to call
it keeping the house in your head yes
it's not just the work you do it's all
of the planes flying around in your head
that have to land about you know that
have to do with yeah yeah the mental
load is a big thing and in fact when I
was writing the book I think it was in
2017 a cartoon illustrating the mental
load went viral and it was awesome it
was perfect it shows everything that mom
has in her head that the father doesn't
really know to think about and it's
really hard to illustrate that stuff to
your partner and if you're the one who's
always on top of it you're the one who
does all the learning so it's kind of a
snowball effect to the solution that's
that's also a great question so I think
the first thing is to really understand
that the sexism out there in our world
permeates our intimate relationships we
don't expect it to we think our homes
are separate from our culture and
they're not at all and I think if you go
into parenting with that realization you
can do the second thing that successful
couples do which is just really stay on
top of how things are being divided it
doesn't need to be split down the middle
50/50 with a hatchet that's not
realistic but if you're constantly
checking in with each other to see how
things are going and people have their
assigned tasks agree upon them and agree
the standards
that those tasks need to kind of need
things work out a lot better so couples
who achieve parity are really on top of
that that is a goal all boils down to
communication yeah thank you thank you
very much thank you go